this week we are partnered with
hellofresh and Rocket money more on them
after the
[Music]
reaction what is happening there
citizens of the reject Nation Roxy and I
had crackers in between cuz we are going
to take a crack at episode two today of
has been Hotel you've been liking the
series loving you want to know what I
just realized what look what's on my
socks it's Jack Skeleton no way which I
feel like is very I feel like I did that
on purpose I think you did it on purpose
subconsciously you were vibing your
empathy registered with the show you are
a Charlotte I go by Charlie uh well you
ruined it all righty guys well if you
didn't catch our reactions to the pilot
that we did four years ago and episode
one that is of course up here on the
Chanel hope you guys stick around for
the reviews we got thoughts it's hard to
interject our thoughts in a show with so
much dial you know what's weird I'm
doing a lot of smiling I feel like I
don't do a lot of smiling during our
reactions I feel like I'm watching this
like a little kid like
yeah oh and smiling always a much better
look on women yeah that's true when
women aren't smiling are they
existing no no we know the answer guys
obious obvious answer don't ask stupid
questions you
dumb broad leave a like and smile while
you do it ladies yeah but men frown all
you want baby boy subscribe and click
that Bell to get notified when I
reaction for episode thrust is up here
on the channel thank you to prepper for
editing down these highlights I'm
assuming you guys did it and you did a
great job at it and fing watch long we
single your own copy of hman Hotel
available for super sex reject our
patreon page or you catch several shows
covered exclusively highight songs
including the first round rock this is
like a Matthew MCC thing you got going
on right now all right all right all
right this is Matthew Matthew MCC pirate
kind of this is called R killed the
video star oh it's going to be a good
one I love that song that's I love that
cuz he hates videos for some reason all
righty well let's do
it extermination is coming in 6 months
instead of a year just a little setback
a little setback Charlie we hand just
Angels cutting our time table in half
but who needs a whole year to save Souls
am I right and next time when they cut
the time in half again we'll just handle
it you can pull it off you can pull it
off you had less than half a chance when
you started all this salvation
ain't no Silver Lining this
time sure there is we just have to look
a little harder for it well while you're
looking the rest of hell is going nuts
oh there's a social media in hell what
is a donkey
show nothing my boss Val is just freaked
out about the news too I would love to
go to a
d never
mind explain yourself Sinners are
desperate may be desperate enough to try
anything to escape the extermination you
could ride the desperate option this is
the perfect time to recruit more Sinners
for the hotel but you're going to have
to lie to them in order to do that but
you're really going to go out in all of
this well it's not like people are just
going to show up on our doorstep whoa
whoo show
yourselves come he the villain's back
Who's Back face my RO who are you Mojo
Jojo I am the great
sentous inventor of architect of
D villain extraordinary unreal ooh he's
a bad boy and we love a bad boy now cow
for when I've slain you the allmighty V
will finally acknowledge me as their
equal ain't going to happen wait who are
the V oh nobody important new Vox Tech
designer of oyos Scopes heaping on the
neighbors has never been more
stylish trust us dud this week's episode
of yeah I your sister so what is brought
to you by box Tech what a reality show I
feel like the shows be so much more
entertaining
[Music]
here wow now that's good
television ooh Brainiac we're going
commentary about the dangers of TV what
are your thoughts on the new
extermination deadline we at Vox Tech
Enterprises have always been at the
Forefront of innovation and now with
this new oncoming threat I feel like
this is spoofing someone we are pleased
to announce Vox Tech Angelic Security is
coming soon coming soon trust us with
you no no it could be like spy wear oh
it's hypnosis cancel all my appointments
today I have a fire to put out
upstairs wow what a neat way of travel
you're fired what is this wrist Ruffles
is it 1750 burn it like the witches who
wore it oh my gosh tell me that's not a
Harley Quinn outfit tell me where's our
hot-headed friend now up in his Tower
waiting for a flat-faced prince to calm
him down love it looks like you have
everything under control here of course
I do you now
shoot I wonder if they recorded in the
same room together some of these scenes
yeah that had such good timing I mean
obviously it's editing but like it felt
like it had yeah the Rhythm and the
listening seems very genuine can you
believe what that piece of did the
ungr
um which are we talking about this time
good question angel
dust walked out on me nice to hear a man
get called we call a lot of you guys
behind your backs he thinks he can run
off and shack up with Lucifer's bimbo
daughter Angel is living with Lucifer's
daughter now Charlie you're not going
over there that slippery twink is going
to remember who owns him I'm going to
everyone in that rancid hole I
swear to
God
the depravity do you want people
thinking you can't control your
employees no you still have them under
contract he isn't going anywhere buo buo
you
should do nothing great idea now that's
why they pay you the big bucks he
putting out so many fires Angel isn't
the only one spending time at this ratty
hotel with the devil's Princessa oh
maybe his villain is the radio guy
Alistair the radio demon is the
there yeah aliser came back and he is
with Lucifer's daughter and that wasn't
the
first you told me oh he's kept this cool
the whole
time I think he's had enough he's got a
few more hits in
him thanks for another forgettable
experience oh God thank you for letting
your God down and
[Music]
but he got part of his
outfit that back yeah I thought he was
gone for good too it's been seven years
seven years same amount of time L is lth
I got to send a message of who's really
in charge of things now welcome home I'm
going to make you wish that You' stayed
gone ha new status quo o everyone knows
that there's a brand new dawn turn the
TV I'm feeling this is going to be like
the villain of your villain is your
friend they're going to all have to band
together against the Angels top of the
hour and we're discussing a certain has
been who has been spotted cing around
town after a seven-year absence did
anybody miss him did anybody notice more
on tonight's program so the radio demon
is back in town why is he hanging around
like even an old school talk show he's a
loser a fossil and I don't mean to sound
hostile but the demon is a coward oh
visual he's barely audible stop giving
him the time of day don't listen to a
word he'd say F but he should have away
God I just want to like slow it down and
get every
[Music]
frame okay okay hell's been better he
split where's he been who gives a
yes I know it's been a while since
someone with style treated hell to a
broadcast Sinners Rejoice what a dated
voice instead of a chasing Mediocre
video podcast oh red and blue is as as
he or is it based on his support he'd be
powerless without the other please what
a fun debate he asked me to join his
team I said no and now he's pissy that's
the team damn these songs are great
really good suffering oh the t is buing
I'll destroy you waa spiderverse I'm
afraid you've lost your
signal radio will Thrive I'm going to
make you wish that i' stayed gone
o when I'm done your status quo will
know its race is run this will be
fun is there any way that he was in
heaven I don't know is his entity that
formed here where was he for seven years
where's Lilith maybe it's part of the
plan yeah Alistair is getting close to
little princess Morning Star so our main
concern now is ensuring that no deal is
ever struck between Lucifer's brat and
that smiling freak Jesus we need someone
who Little Miss bleeding heart would
take in someone pathetic with no direct
ties to us I have no idea I think I have
just the one we haven't met the
character yet right
we have we don't know not a single new
recruit who would want to use their last
days not and fighting fair fair I didn't
come looking for a fight I heard that
you're helping people people who want to
be better there's so much little shifts
in the eyes to capture the emotion and
on every character Welcome to our home
of healing this chump was trying to kill
us and now you want to bring him in here
to live with us the porn star speaks
scripture welcome
to the hasbin hotel oh no darling thank
you this is terrible idea I'm just so
excited to have our first real guest uh
what the hell am I then you're an
important part of our family here angel
but you um constantly make us look bad
harass the staff and have literally
never once tried to
improve you've met our newest guest sir
penes you're the one who ruined my coat
I definitely remember you you now he is
scary really truly this is a great time
for your first lesson how to apologize
the first step to becoming a better
person is to admit when you are wrong
please forgive me for attacking you and
ruining your very lovely coat he could
fix his own coat easily I think it's
important we all get to know each other
so we are going to play a little game
Truth or Dare my name is Charlie I like
to sing and when we get to know each
other it's the greatest thing my name's
PES I like to build and despite my
stupid egg boys I think I'm very skilled
not bad bars not bad bars this is stupid
this is not stupid it's just the
game she's got like an Amy polar
attitude about her it's very um parks
and R yeah exactly I'm a bad man on the
streets who never got enough hugs Now
where's an innocent kid I can sell to
you look like a kid who could use some
Devil's dant who was underlined I have
to go home and study it'll make you cool
like me the
[Music]
crackhead if you'll excuse me I'm off to
not have sexual intercourse before
marriage right that would send you to
hell I used to believe that really yeah
you're married now yeah this raid you'll
be redeemed in no time I'm going to bed
I am so proud of you sir penes that was
amazing there's so much shaming they do
towards is this pronoun him is it a his
him I don't know yeah I'm pretty sure
that everybody's been calling him he him
yeah angel baby come home it's not the
same without here I miss you come back
don't take the boat if you don't come
home you will be greasy truckers for the
next year hey I'm morito I didn't mean
to yell oh my God Valentino's like Elvis
Presley from Priscilla this has happened
to me and so many of my friends piece of
you actually think why didn't you
just return the call attic trash like
you doesn't
change I'll see you soon baby now it's
layered they are layered they're not
just as much of SE
jokes you're working for the V I don't
know what you're talking about
bug
[Music]
they just like to do she's going to see
get your aggressive going to off of me
now body shaming this little is a
traitor
Preposterous I would never betray you
you are my best friends best friends
then explain
this you didn't even try to get rid of
it SOS agent little
moving you were caught it hasn't even
been a day see said it wouldn't be a
week and do us a favor if they don't
kill you go ahead and do it yourself you
miserable failure a now I want him to be
part of them team oh maybe this was part
of it maybe he was trying to get caught
on purpose just quick I guess wait no
see penious so P pretentious penious
she's going to take him in now
starts he did that on purpose now he's
going to really
reform a what a sweet sweet notion
spoken straight from your core the path
to
forgiveness is a twisting trail of
Hearts she is so sweet sorry is where it
starts
a who could forgive a dirt bag like me
she could I don't deserve your
amnesty can't we just kill
him him and spill his
blood love there's actual heart to this
show
man
I sorry sorry sorry say one sinc sorry
I'm so
sorry I'm so
sorry she's making them work for it
Craig it'll take to cover my vude
of where it
begin it's like a children's lesson song
I hated that song hey it was touching
good first day let's get some rest oh
he's sticking around yeah where's he
going to
go what you'll have to try harder than
that next time old
pal wow it's getting
better good s off so good it's just
getting better I wonder where it's going
thank you to America's number one meal
kid hellofresh for partnering with us
it's always great to partner with people
whose Services you actually use because
as someone like me who's always juggling
a pack schedule between filming and
editing finding time for healthy eating
can be a challenge that's where
hellofresh has been a GameChanger for my
life with hellofresh I get Farm Fresh
pre portioned ingredients and delicious
recipes delivered right to my doorstep
so I don't have to step outside it's
revolutionized my home cooking
experience making it not just easy but
super enjoyable and affordable keyw I
recently tried their delicious barbecue
pineapple flatbreads and their zucchini
pomodora Panet bake both were
mouthwatering delicious and fit
perfectly with my pescatarian lifestyle
pescatarian mm s fancy and asking my
friends who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a
meat eater again people I know I've
really recommended their lemon parsley
chicken palard I think is how you
pronounce it in the fuo chicken faito
tacos regardless hellofresh menu has
something for everyone but of course
it's not just about the food it's about
saving time too not having a wait in
line at a grocery store even self
checkouts on fast enough these days the
convenience of having everything
delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with her
quick and easy meals like 15-minute
recipes spending less time in the
kitchen and more time doing what I love
which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to
support the channel and also support you
know having a new lifestyle healthy
affordable lifestyle in the year 2024 go
to hellofresh.com reject free and use
code rejects free for free breakfast for
life you heard that right one breakfast
item per box while the subscription is
active free breakfast for life for
hellofresh.com reject free use promo
code reject free try it out and let me
know your favorite dishes stay healthy
and let's keep enjoying those movies and
shows all right reject Nation let's get
real for a moment running this channel
is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for
the channel and my personal life can be
overwhelming that's where Rocky money
has been a financial Lifesaver for me
even before I ever partnered up with
them like I said I've been very
fortunate to be working with Brands
whose products I already use so it's a
win-win for him walk but it can be a
win-win for you too cuz there's a reason
I use them rocket money is a personal
finance app that simplifies managing
money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and
crafting a budget that fits your
specific lifestyle for someone like me
who can easily lose track of expenses
throughout every single day of the month
it's been eye openening to see where I
was overspending stuff I don't use that
I kept paying for especially apps man I
was way too many apps rocket money does
the heavy lifting by analyzing your
spending then customizes notifications
to help you stay within your budget
goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling
your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly
subscriptions too so many free trials I
signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free trial was
done making it super easy to cancel the
ones you don't use couple of clicks and
you're putting money back in your pocket
telling you have you ever found hidden
subscriptions or pay for services you
forgot about because rocket money is a
huge asset and helping to uncover those
and even negotiate some of my bills down
to with like 20% so if you're ready to
take control of your finances and
there's no better time than now because
it is the beginning of the year check
out rocket money and see how much you
could be saving stop wasting money on
things you do not use so to help support
the channel and help support your wallet
visit rocket money.com rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of 7 $120 a year with over $500
million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident
they'll do the same for you that's
rocket money.com rejects your bank
account will thank you we got to figure
out what's going on with heaven we got
to figure out what's going on we need to
know what's up with Lilith we need to
know where uh evil radio man was for
seven years I have so many questions
well regardless I I think that this
episode in of
itself I think there's always been a
heart here it starts off with a heart
from the very from the pilot obviously
our main character has a heart but
what's kind of been um a little bit
missing for me with this journey is it
only seemed like Charlie's the only one
with a heart and what I liked with this
one did was it gave us a heart for every
for not everyone but you know for more
characters in ways that were kind of
unexpected and nuanced and then even
like having things that were like oh
this is like a joke thing you know
there's a lot of like you know sexual
jokes and um deviant like jokes but then
that moment with Valentino and Angel on
the phone to capture this Dynamic where
he was leaving all these like the
gaslighting voicemail with the rage and
then no I'm I'm being apologetic you're
like that's a very real thing MH that a
lot of people go
through you were saying during the
reaction that you've been through that
did you deserve that though
never because I have self love I I think
that it's interesting to hear you say
that it was missing a little bit of the
heart for you because I feel like the
heart has been shining through the whole
time not just with Charlie but also her
bestie like looking at her bestie like I
I love because Charlie wants to do the
right thing because Charlie wants to
save everybody and she seems like
obviously the best human in Hell the
best person or best whatever it is in
hell but her bestie like is doing it all
for Charlie she doesn't seem to care
about anything else I mean yeah right I
disregard her I'm talking about like how
they layered other characters who have
been kind of okay like the whole thing
with Angel was yeah he loves to do it
you know that that's been the whole
character of Angel and then
they yeah you know is it escapism and
then they and they they took things that
were they were just making a lot of
jokes about that were really funny they
were genuinely funny and then they added
the like oh there's actually a real
there's a bit of a realism touch to it
with uh how people like shame Angel all
the time and you can see that that
actually gets to Angel a little bit you
know yeah completely and and also when
Charlie started giving more attention to
the other guy and Angel feels left out
and everybody wants to be part of
something and when you see other people
being the best versions of themselves or
looking like they're getting um support
it makes you want to be better yeah and
then even the serpent character I I
forget the snake the snake character's
name them coming here with this motive
and yeah we know the kind of character
that he was set up as in the p
but even him like the tears felt at
least you know it's animation to me they
seem sincere when the tears are coming
out and then uh while still caught up in
the Showmanship of it all with like oh
this is this is such a reward to say I'm
sorry like there's is like feeling so
good about yourself for like look how
look how humbling I am about myself I
like that they put that in some of the
musical performance of that I'm sorry
song uh but there's a there's a genuine
good like first step lesson there and it
was the first time in this whole journey
of Rehabilitation other than the the
cause where you could see oh maybe
Charlie with these kind of baby steps
there is a real path where you can
connect with people like taking
something where you know we shouldn't
have trust this guy he should be
punished but instead of punishing doing
the exact opposite of that and learning
how to forgive I I thought
actually good message there's always
been a heart I think this is the episode
the heart shine through the most which
is funny because in the animation this
was the episode that I noticed that
there was so many hearts involved that
is true you did point that out yeah
that's why you're the TV girl once I had
love it was a gas soon found out Heart
of Glass yeah yeah yeah some deep
whatever you just
[Music]
said no I don't know what you're doing
really what is
[Music]
that oh yeah Blondie and imagine roller
blad go Harry yeah and that's just so
good the the TV guy what you think the
TV guy
Roxy I'm I am interested also because we
know Alistair does no TV no TV no TV
radio radio radio and disappeared for
seven years and TV guy hates him yeah
but is he worried to be on TV because
he's worried to be
found
uh like a like uh no I mean he's tell
he's he's reported on and and uh
televised put he made a commercial and
stuff oh that's good point Al was in it
yeah he made the camera and then he was
in it yeah oh wait oh it's causing me to
like kind of think about that uh because
his voice was on it but I don't know if
his
actual face voice yeah I know just was
something I was thinking about but yeah
I I love the rivalries we're creating
there's a lot of layers to this and
there's a lot of Dynamics and because
they do put that time period of seven
years it's like wow a ton has happened
and it gives us a lot to play with for
not just a few episodes but I could see
this being a very long running show yeah
which but everything is so precise like
every sh every shot they they make it
count yeah you know and yes that's so
true a lot of World building a lot of
World building and I I love what they do
with the eyes on this show because they
especially on the TV guys when I really
start to notice it which made me kind of
pay attention to everyone's eyes they'll
do the littlest movements and that's
where so much of the emotion can get
lost if animation is not properly
executed if you if you're not capturing
it through that's like the window to the
soul is what they say right and I think
this show does it Exquisite job with
everyone because sometimes you're not
just dealing with humans you're dealing
with like the TV guy for example is not
traditional eyeballs but there like the
whatever voice he was like it always
adjusted to whatever little change of
emotion he had I was so wowed by like
the S the littlest details cu the show
is so many
details every second of it that you're
like wow I got to watch it again so I
could see what's going on be in the
background or yeah it's extremely detail
oriented that's a good point what do you
think about the balance between the
music versus non-m music do you think
that it's the right amount of songs per
episode do you wish there was more oh I
think it's right I think it's perfect me
too I feel that I think that they're
doing a really good job of not
overloading it but also the moments we
break out into song Feel earned and make
sense and they're
really sometimes I have to kind of
attune or adjust my the way I pay
attention when a musical number comes in
for certain shows or M movies in
particular and whenever the songs come
here they're so ingrained within the
dialogue and the story because there's
such a perform it's more than just
hitting notes there is a performance and
and they often carry on the dialogue
with it too you like sometime some of
these for the most part I feel like I
think you could put I think you can put
any of these songs on at any point just
like queue it up listen but it it works
so much better within the content yeah
put it on in the club the clubs where
the kids go you go to Club still do you
Club I'm a big clubber Greg are you
how'd you know do you do you go clubbing
a big clubber sometimes I see on
like the socials you're like at a club I
don't know where you're at it doesn't
say where you're at I'm not trying
hitting you up being like where you at
rock is it a club yeah always do you go
to clubs mhm yeah I don't like clubs pig
into clubs I go to a club and I'm just
like I don't belong here me and all the
young ones are there you look young I am
Young
yeah I said
look but you have a heart of glass but
the um Shad the hold up what are we
talking about the club playing the music
Bal that's actually what we were talking
about yeah the uh the the musical
numbers yes a great question thank you
and the question was about I got my
wisdom for being at the club just the
balance of the music that you and I both
think that they're doing a good job
balancing it yeah I think the the it is
a reward when you that's the word I
would probably associate with it it's
rewarding when the song comes in tasty
treat you're like oh yay another one
yeah and you you pointed out too in the
one last one uh what you call it with
like the dueling songs the the Duets or
was that you said I don't know it it was
Greg I said a lot of smart things it's
hard to keep up I mean we can kind of
count at least too uh yeah well like how
the TV guy and the radio guy were going
back and forth what did you call that it
was there the right terminology I don't
know what I called it what what are we
doing here on the internet if we don't
the terminology sound stupid there right
now oh St me look stupid yes and yes and
we'll see you guys for episode three was
that two I don't
remember oh the radio killed the video
star yeah yeah I think it's two mhm okay
so we got two more to watch and then we
take a little breather but then they
drop how did they release these episodes
I have no idea they put it on the
internet for people to watch on uh ant
Prime video Oh I thought they invited
everybody over to their house yeah and
then they just spread the
word just like they spread their legs
okay
oh don't body shame yourself no that was
that was to you angel
dust close out
foxy sexies
re uh we're going to watch episode three
now and we're stoked to it because this
show is awesome don't be a has been keep
joining the journey and be a current Ben
yeah B is past term yeah
[Music]
bye